I'm hungry I want some pizza I'm going
to order some pizza hi I'd like to place
an order for delivery please okay oh I'm
sorry I was I was looking to order a
pizza I might just have the wrong symbol
hello oh I just wanted to place an order
for delivery hello oh the gate up cheese
and sausage pizza if you have harm and
also not pan on that pizza hi ayuk I go
to place order for delivery please Oh
nope it's ugly glue a sausage and cheese
oh yes I just wanted to place an order
for delivery oh um I'm sorry I thought I
was calling for pizza oh I just don't
even get on so sorry I guess I can maybe
get to look at an iPhone pizza or
something but hi Matt I just wanted to
place an order for delivery okay so one
donates more pizza just from here how
did you purchase something already and
you just want to step into everyday or
you want to furnish something to happen
no I was looking to alternate and for
delivery think that you have like
several different sizes that I have a
coupon actually it says for two extra
large pizza with pepperoni I would love
to send you two large pepperoni pizzas
with no mattress store we always open
I would cheese well I've got two coupons
so I will send you my extra pizza
oh yes I just wanted to place an order
for delivery please I would like two
large pizza with pepperoni uh extra
cheese also um I think either coupon and
it says that that comes with a liter of
Pepsi
and the thought oh don't thank yes
it said honey bonnets oh I don't think
so I've never actually had a honey bun
before how come my job is
that a little bit no pests on the honey
balls why one o'clock
no one just never had a honey bun
tonight I just think you're being a
little bit I didn't try to get you money
but you wouldn't you that's a long a bit
to confuse a doubt I just never had a
honey bun but if what isn't even swell
I've never sworn in your life
oh yes oh and Pepsi because I'll just
cuz you're supposed to deliver me a
pizza oh my goodness I think um I'm a
little bit uncomfortable but up if you
were a little bit uncomfortable okay
thank you the dolly you don't want to go
stay together
I guess I'm not gonna get to pizza I am
I